[Applaudissements]
il faut vraiment que je me reprenne en
main ça c'est ce que je me suis dit
lorsque j'ai vu cette photo donc cette
photo a été prise en 2019 ici à bsb et
au moment où elle a été prise je me
doutais absolument pas que j'étais sur
le point de partir à l'aventuré sur les
routes du monde que j'allais rencontrer
thomas en chemin au chili précisément et
que deux ans plus tard j'allais me
retrouver ici à billets ce but sur la
scéne ted avec dix kilos de moins et
plein d'histoires à vous raconter
lorsque cette photo a été prise justin
et moi ne nous connaissions pas encore
mais ma vie était aussi à l'orée d'un
grand changement dix ans plus tôt en
2009 ma famille et moi partir vivre à
tokyo ce furent cinq années formidables
à l'autre bout du monde cinq années
d'échangés interculturels
mais le retour en france a été
particulièrement difficile pour tous les
membres de ma famille parce que passer
de la mégalopole japonaise à la banlieue
parisienne c'est un peu compliqué
mais heureusement quelques années plus
tard ma vie allait changer grâce à cette
chose dont on va vous parler aujourd'hui
et dont on est très fiers d'eux d'avoir
fait l'expérience l' aventure donc vous
l'aurez compris le point commun aux deux
histoire c'est que l'aventuré a changé
nos vies mais pendant longtemps on ne
savait pas vraiment expliquer ce qui au
sein de nos aventures dans nous c'est en
changer nous faisait tant évolué qu'est
ce qui rend laventure si bouleversante
c'est une vaste question on est tous
déjà partis en vacances une ou deux
semaines et puis à notre tour on sent un
petit peu transformés non c'est pas
vraiment expliquer pourquoi alors on
laisse la routine reprend le dessus et
on met ça de côté on garde une certitude
en nous la prochaine fois qu'on
repartira on va à nouveau ressentir
cette émotion puissante qui nous
transporte
nous on s'est dit avec justin que si on
trouver la source de ce changement on
pourrait l'implémenter dans notre
quotidien pour faire de nos vies des
expériences en constante mutation alors
on va vous expliquer les différentes
quêtes dans lesquels on s'est lancée et
les conclusions qu'on a attiré afin de
tenter de répondre à cette question
qu'est ce qui fait de l' aventure une
telle source de changement
alors oui il faut vraiment que je me
reprenne en main le penser c'est bien
c'est une première étape mais finalement
ça me c'est pas vraiment ce que je
devais faire alors j'ai réfléchi pendant
longtemps pendant de nombreuses soirées
et finalement au soir la réponse elle
même un peu apparu comme une évidence la
première chose que je devais faire et
que je voulais faire c'était quitté ma
zone de confort alors un peu sur un coup
de tête j'ai décidé de partir en échange
universitaire à montréal au canada et là
bas j'ai eu la chance d'aller à toronto
à niagara à ottawa boston new york j'ai
eu la chance de faire du chien de
traîneau d'aller aux chutes du niagara
et finalement toutes ces villes toutes
ces expériences qui me paraissait hyper
l'antenne est totalement inaccessible eh
ben c'est devenu ma réalité donc
finalement c'était peut-être ça le
premier déclic dont j'avais besoin
quatre mois d'échangés universitaires à
l'étranger toute fière de mon côté comme
je vous le disais où mon retour en
france a été un peu difficile et à la
fin du lycée j'ai géré intérieurement
durant ses années en banlieue parisienne
heureusement mon antre en études
supérieures a été libératrice
j'ai décidé de quitter ma zone de
confort qui était alors la paresse la
complainte et l'illusoire sécurité des
murs de ma chambre et j'ai décidé de me
mettre au travail je suis passé de
dernier de la classe en terminale a
major de promotion en première année
d'études supérieures j'ai aussi passé de
casaniers maladif qui pouvait passer
tout l'été reclus dans son cloître dans
sa chambre un étudiant cosmopolite
puisque en 2018 j'ai voyagé dans 10 pays
j'ai notamment eu la chance de partir en
échange universitaire en irlande en
stage hôtelier au panama de faire ma
première randonnée la traversée des
vosges à pied
et voilà et de me dépasser de me changer
de partir à l'aventuré et ça ça m'a fait
un bien fou et en fait ça on a ressenti
cette chose commune qui est que quand on
quitte sa zone de confort il se passe
des choses totalement a prévu et ça nous
a donné envie d'aller plus loin de nous
lancer dans des projets encore plus
ambitieux voilà c'était formidable alors
après tout ça j'ai moi aussi voulu me
lancer vous savez comment le larousse
définit l aventure il s'agit de toute
entreprise ou le risque est considérable
et dont la réussite est douteuse alors
moi aussi j'ai voulu me lancer dans
quelque chose d'un petit peu fou pour
moi
et j'ai toujours eu l'habitude de
voyager avec ma famille très entouré et
et après le canada je suis parti faire
un stage au chili et j'en ai profité
pour faire du parachute l'ascension du
volcan et en même temps je suis allé
tout seul sur une île achille wes
emeline au large du continent sud
américain est il finalement en étant
seul sur cette île alors que j'avais pas
du tout l'habitude de faire ça eh ben
j'ai rencontré tout un tas de personnes
et je me suis rendu compte que
finalement voyager tout seul bah j'en
étais capable
ouais moi de mon côté j'ai trouvé refuge
à autrement depuis ma chambre dans la
maison familiale des yvelines je vais
trouver refuge dans les récits
d'aventuriers explorateurs tels que mike
horn sarah marquis jean louis etienne où
sylvain tesson je sais pas si ces noms
vous disent quelque chose mais moi ils
ont porté ces années un peu d'errance
intérieur ils ont été un soutien
émotionnel pour moi et ses récits jeu
jour après jour ligne après ligne mais
habitait à partir à l'aventuré à partir
encore plus loin du coup j'ai décidé
d'entreprendre une ma première aventure
et je la démo que j'aimerais vous
partager aujourd'hui c'est ce que
sylvain tesson écrit dans sa cabane
sibérienne sur les rives du lac baïkal
cd livres cd mines qui sont extraits de
son livre dans les forêts de sibérie
parce que les participants en héritage
là bas il ya une scène qui m'a marqué il
dit alors que la lumière s'épuise de
faire des trous dans les nuages je me
couche sur la plage devant un feu de
bois les chiens contre le flanc le kayak
remontée de moitié sur la rive et
écoutant la musique de la houle je
regarde griller mes poissons embrocher
sur des pics de bois vert en pensant que
la vie ne devrait être que cela
l'hommage rendu par l'adulte à ses rêves
d'enfant c'est magnifique et moi en
lisant ça j'avais envie de rendre
hommage à mes rêves d'enfant alors il
fallait que j'aille plus loin il fallait
que j'aie entreprennent la première
expédition une aventure qui nous
permettrait d'aller au bout de ma quête
identitaire et de me découvrir en enfin
totalement et d'avoir des des réponses
aux questions que je me posais depuis
toujours donc j'ai décidé d'entreprendre
la première expédition la traversée du
salar du salar d'uyuni en bolivie le
plus grand désert de sel du monde
je vais vous mettre le
le désert de sel on s'est un petit peu
trompé dans les slides celle aventure
aussi de faire certaines est alors moi
j'ai jamais été taillé pour l'aventuré
je suis timide en société j'ai le
vertige
j'ai très peur en voiture justin en fait
les frais je me parle toujours en tant
que copilote et voilà des scènes comme
se taisent ou peut être un peu anxieux
mais sur la route il se passe quelque
chose d'assez fou on prend confiance en
soi et moi je ressens cela je ressens
une un bouleversement je deviens plus
téméraires plus fort plus je me vois
plus grand essai c'est agréable de voir
comme ça et je me suis jamais senti
aussi bien que dans ce désert au milieu
du sel ça a été une expérience si
agréable et si je me sifflent que
j'avais six des neuf jours après être
sorti de ce salaire là alors que ce
n'était pas du tout prévu de repartir
pour un deuxième désert le salar
d'atacama au chili
donc l'environnement est totalement
différent parce que le salar d'uyuni où
l'on dénivelé par louis la moitié de
l'année le salaire d'atacama se trouve
dans une des régions les plus arides du
monde du coup on a ces cdt recharger en
selle mais qui sont bruni et qui
ressemble plus à mars donc c'est c'est
magnifique et voilà j'ai fait une
nouvelle aventure de cinq jours et 100
km là bas une nouvelle semaine
d'intensité de pureté et de silence en
l'honneur de mes rêves d'enfant et
finalement mais aussi toute seule sur
cette île achille ou et j'avais
l'impression de n'avoir jamais été aussi
proche de mes rêves d'enfant parce que
dans la maison familiale de mes parents
là où j'ai grandi dans les vosges
j'ai toujours été très entouré avec
beaucoup d'amour et l'amour de ma
famille c'était vraiment l'essence même
de mon monde est absolument rien ne
prédestinait à à m'éloigner tout ça et
finalement en partant tout seul à
l'étranger je me suis rendu compte que
est bon le monde me paraissait plus
petit plus accessible ou bien peut-être
que c'est moi qui avait grandi c'est sûr
que ça nous faisait grandir de partir
dans des terres éloignées de nous
rencontrer dans des aventures qui nous
paraissait si tu as les jantes mais de
mon côté quelque chose ne changeait pas
à moins qu'il était toujours là à chaque
retour j'avais toujours se vider ce
besoin de repartir pour à nouveau
redevenir l'homme fort et du coup
peut-être qu'après l'expérience de
solitude la véritable aventure qui
m'attendait qui pouvait me transformer
profondément c'est l aventure du partage
était peut-être temps que nous partions
ensemble
alors après le désert de sel thomas est
parti un semestre en uruguay et ensuite
à son tour il est venu en stage au chili
là bas on s'est rencontrés on sait
apprécier on s'est vus et et finalement
s'est dit pourquoi pas de partir
ensemble donc on avait tout prévu notre
voyage en amérique du sud tout était
planifié jusqu'à l'arrivée du coc vide
donc on a dû rentrer en france et en
rentrant thomas m'a dit et s'ils ont
traversé la france en roller alors tout
de suite il a envoyé un mail à décathlon
en leur précisant qu'on voulait
traverser la france du nord au sud et
que pour ça on avait besoin deux paires
de rollers et finalement ça a marché
donc on s'est retrouvé avec le premier
projet en commun notre premier sponsor
et maintenant on avait plus que 1300 km
de roller à faire plutôt simple plutôt
simple dit comme ça c'est assez simple
cette aventure sportive s'est rapidement
domine avant tout une aventure humaine
parce que tous les soirs notre objectif
c'était de sonner à des portes et de
demander aux locaux si on pouvait camper
dans leur jardin ça c'était notre
prétexte en fait on mettait la main mais
on voulait le bras nous donc on disait
on entre dans le jardin et puis au final
on dînait avec eux et de temps en temps
on avait une chambre dans la maison et
tous les soirs on était accueillie on
est accueillis dès la première maison
voire la deuxième ou la troisième tout
au plus on n'a jamais eu à chercher bien
longtemps et ça c était assez incroyable
de se rendre compte que que les gens
nous ouvrait aussi facilement leurs
portes et on a rencontré plusieurs
dizaines de familles françaises comme ça
mais bon ce voyage il n'a pas été tout
rose parce que après 200 kilomètres de
roller je me suis baissier à notre
arrivée à reims je me suis fait une
luxation du genou qui m'a obligé à
arrêter et pour moi c'est une blessure à
la été très très difficile parce que je
les ai vraiment vécu comme un échec j'ai
l'impression d'y avoir tout raté ne pas
pouvoir continuer avec thomas donc j'ai
dû rentrer chez moi faire une pause
pendant deux semaines et je n'arrivais
pas à me dire que je dois arrêter ce que
les médecins m'ont dit le roller c'est
fini la peine donc je me suis dit je
peux pas arrêter je peux pas m'arrêter
en si bon chemin je veux continuer sur
la route je veux continuer à rencontrer
du monde donc finalement j'ai décidé de
reprendre la route après deux semaines
de rééducation je suis reparti avec
thomas mais cette fois ci à vélo et
finalement après deux mois on a quand
même atteint tous les la frontière
franco-espagnole tome en rollers et moi
et mon vélo cette aventure en france
elle a été merveilleuse le pays qui nous
avaient finalement le plus dépaysé
c'était la france et quelques mois avant
lorsqu'on était en amérique du sud
justin avait traversé la patagonie en
vannes et moi avec un ami il avait
traversé quelques semaines plus tard en
auto stop et sans argent la bonne avait
fait énormément de rencontres mais à
notre retour en france évidemment nos
proches nous avait dit ça a été possible
parce que c'était en amérique du sud la
basse et une culture latine en france
c'est impossible les gens sont si
méchants ils sont antipathiques qui se
plaignent les français donc globalement
vous serez toujours à recaler à tous les
portails bas c'était faux on savait
désormais que ça c'était une certitude
qu'ils étaient fausses et que l'
aventure se trouver partout et surtout
chez nous et ça ça nous a bouleversés ça
nous a donné envie d'arrêter de voyager
seulement pour nous ça nous a donné
envie de donner plus de sens à ce que
l'on faisait ça nous a donné envie de
nous engager désormais nos aventures se
devait d'être engagé parce que tant
partir pour tenter de se changer se
passait bien mais partir pour changer le
monde c'est mieux les conséquences du
changement climatique c'est quelque
chose qui nous paraît toujours assez
lointain assez complexe ne concerne pas
vraiment mais cet été cette année pour
la première fois les conséquences elles
étaient vraiment à nos portes donc on a
vu des gelées tardives qui ont détruit
des récoltes entières ici en bourgogne
en même temps il ya un dôme de chaleur
au canada avec des températures
avoisinant les 50 degrés et puis les
états unis la grèce était sous des feux
totalement incontrôlable pendant que
nous en france en chine en allemagne on
a eu des pluies diluviennes qui ont fait
augmenter le fonds entraîné la montée
des eaux et des glissements de terrain
de nombreux morts et en voyant tout ça
avec te ment aussi dit peut-être que
nous aussi on a envie de faire quelque
chose au moins à notre échelle depuis un
peu plus d'un an on est tous les deux
devenu végétarien et on a tous les deux
rejoignent association qui s'appelle
l'association des jeunes ambassadeurs
pour le climat avec laquelle on fait des
conférences pour sensibiliser d'autres
jeunes aux enjeux environnementaux
mais cette année face à tous ces
dérèglements climatiques face à tous
toutes ces catastrophes
environnementales
on s'est dit que ce n'est pas suffisant
qu'il était temps d'agir concrètement
d'avoir une action terrain et on s'est
dit pourquoi pas le nier une aventure à
une action concrète alors on a décidé
d'entreprendre notre première éco
aventure je me suis toujours senti très
concerné par les enjeux marin et je suis
d'ailleurs en train d'écrire mon mémoire
de fin d'étude sur l'exploitation des
ressources halieutiques et du coup avec
thomas on voulait avoir une action un
peu plus sur le terrain et on s'est
intéressé à la fondation surfrider et
notamment à leur projet plastique origin
qui vise à recenser et cartographier la
pollution des cours d'eau européens on
leur a parlé de notre projet de
descendre la loire en kayak de nevers à
tour sur un peu plus de 300 km et de
vouloir amasser recenser nos déchets ils
ont adhéré à notre projet et en même
temps c'est dit et surtout on a nos
premiers partenaires décathlon et qu on
leur parlait de ce projet un peu fou et
ils nous ont subi ils nous ont donné
tout le kit parfait pour être un bon éco
aventurier ce rôle nous a tellement plu
est d éco aventurier des bons élèves en
fête et s'amuser en faisant quelque
chose d'intéressant et de qui a du sens
qu'on a envie de repartir faire des
projets comme ça à forte valeur ajoutée
pour nous pour les autres pour
l'histoire et l'expérience qu'on en
retire donc notre objectif c'est de
partir en octobre 2022 dans un an de
paris et jusqu'à dakar et vélo ça paraît
un peu fou dit comme ça nous aussi on a
du mal à y croire mais on va le faire et
franchement on aimerait récolter des
témoignages sur de la part des habitants
de la zone saharienne sur les menaces
climatiques présentes et futures qui
pèsent sur eux et on aimerait faire d un
cycle de conférences à notre tour auprès
d'autres jeunes est à nouveau en
partenariat avec l'association dont nous
sommes membres
dans la zone saharienne il ya des choses
très compliquées qui s'amusent à
quelques exemples serait de dire la
hausse de la température
l'effondrement de la biodiversité marine
qui impacte les pêcheurs sur la façade
atlantique la montée des eaux le baisse
des taux la baisse des rendements
agricoles des crises migratoires des
sécheresses et ça c'est que quelques
exemples on sait qu'on est très loin des
objectifs d 1,5 degré des accords de
paris mais on peut encore faire tout
notre possible pour faire du personnel
pour faire en sorte que le pire scénario
du giec ne devienne pas une réalité et
pour ça il est urgent de décarbonés ne
vit maintenant et drastiquement
donc partir à l'aventuré de manière éco
responsable c'est probablement la
manière la plus responsable de voyage et
qu'on ait pu tester alors après avoir
quitté une zone de confort après être
parti tout seul dans le désert ou mois
sur une île après partir ensemble en
quête de belles rencontres et avoir
réalisé notre première éco aventure à
chacun de nos retours de nos voyages on
avait toujours cette envie de repartir
tout le temps en quête d'une chose que
finalement l'aventuré elle met tout le
temps en évidence et elle rend si
évidente c'est limbourg
alors oui ça paraît si bateau est si
facile de dire ça voilà on l'a dit mais
moi je peux vous assurer quand on a 20
ans on est un peu perdu intérieur moins
qu'on est au milieu d'un désert et qu'on
a ce vite face à nous et qu'il faut se
donner du courage tout seul pour avancer
surtout qu'à ce moment là j'ai pas de
moyen de communication qui n'a pas la
possibilité d'appeler mes parents en cas
de problème ou des amis et je peux vous
assurer qu'on se rend compte que la vie
elle tient des choses simples et moi je
me suis rendu compte là bas à quel point
mon désir de rendre fiers les gens que
j'aime ça pouvait nous porter veut
changer me transformer et c'est ça qui
est au fond quel que soit le but de mes
aventures faisait de moi une personne
peut être plus forte que dans le
quotidien et pour ma part après ma
blessure en france en rollers finalement
en fait c'est le soutien de thomas le
soutien de ma famille qui m'a donné une
force que je soupçonnais absolument pas
donc finalement quand on y réfléchit
qu'on se demande qu'est ce qui fait de
l' aventure une telle source de
changement il vend ses les rencontres
c'est la solidarité c'est les
encouragements ses labours finalement
derrière chaque aventurier derrière
chaque explorateurs se cache un
entourage des amis une famille des amis
qui les soutiennent et les inspire et
peut-être plus encore que leur
expédition ce sont peut-être ces
relations qui constitue la plus grande
aventure de leur vie parce que l'amour
est la plus grande source de changement
dans nos vies parce que l'amour est la
plus belle des raisons de se dépasser
parce que l'amour est la plus grande des
aventures
[Applaudissements]